all night tonight we've been taking you
through the filmmaking process as we
present this year's Oscars we started
with the script added in our essential
production elements design costumes hair
and makeup and cinematography once
shooting begins the footage eventually
ends up in the skillful hands of an
editor the subtle brilliance of this
next group of artists comes through in
the almost invisible rhythms of great
filmmaker here are the nominees for
achievement in film editing the big
short Hank call ready a spotlight
Kennedy Tom McArdle fury the revenant
Steven Maroney Star Wars The Force
awakens Mary Anne Brandon and major
Marty Mad Max fury road Margaret sixel
the Oscar goes to Margaret sixel
the first Oscar nomination for Margaret
six
Wow
Valley ice mag boxes are doing okay
tonight thank you so much to the Academy
you know Mad Max was the best reviewed
film of 2015 audiences loved it and to
be honored tonight is just more than we
could ever have hoped for but it took
enormous creative courage and guts to
make this film so I just want to say
thanks to George Miller Doug Mitchell
and the whole crew that endured six
months and at the Libyan desert to bring
back the most amazing footage but
honestly it's in the Edit room that the
final that the film is finally forged
it's the final rewrite so I just want to
salute my beloved picture department -
in Sydney and all who work in post who
work with their hands heads and most
importantly their hearts